as we make way for one of the great
shooters of all time Hall of Famer
Reggie Miller did you watch last night I
did reluctantly yes I watch I will say
this if I was not coming on this show
this morning I doubt I would have
watched last night not saying I would
not have watched let's say today at some
point but I probably would not have
watched last night because it's a
homework assignment it was because I
wanted to know you know follow along
what you were going to ask me but also
for I don't want people to think you
know why is he hating I'm not hating
because it's more out of hurtful respect
because for those of us who were called
by central casting to be in this movie
versus the Bulls in the 90s we lived it
I lived it so I don't need to actually
see it now there were some things that
because they had a camera crew following
them there were certain things that you
did not know because you know Jordans
been sitting on this footage for you
know 25 30 years
you did not know but for those of us who
actually lived it and played against him
and were you know trying to compete with
them
I didn't need to watch the doc to know
it brought back a lot of those good and
bad memories of going against that dude
were you interviewed for this again
reluctantly yeah I tried to fight it I
actually did I didn't want to do it you
know that Michael had to approve
everybody who was going to be
interviewed and so so he had to approve
that you were correct correct and I did
not want I wasn't going to do it and I
fought it and I wasn't going to do it
and I had everyone from the league
office saying you need to be a part of
this and everyone at Turner telling me I
needed to be a part of this I was like
no no go No
no go no I don't need to be a part of it
and then I was like look baby it was it
was a healing part of it too to talk
about you know the I want people to
think that it was some big robbery
because a rivalry to me is we are we are
on equal footing I was never on equal
footing with MJ okay
but I loved the battles and I know a lot
of players that I played against they
would bow down to him and that just was
not going to be me I just it was not in
my nature to do that so maybe I was
hard-headed maybe I should have bowed
down to him but it was good to talk
about it and some of those times to help
myself move on Theodore yeah I'm
surprised to hear that that it but you
know that maybe you needed to move on it
was cathartic and a wedding like you've
been holed up you like you may not have
liked him but you certainly respected
him but did you learn anything new about
this as you went through the process
well it's funny because on this show
even though we've you know since I think
I've been on the show 5 6 7 years maybe
even longer and I've stated he years ago
he's the greatest player of all time you
know III missed no words about that you
know I talked about him and Kobe you
know in him and LeBron to me there is
that they're not even in the same breath
or league but it's funny you know when
you hear about the whole Jerry Crowell
and blowing up the team you know people
need to understand he put the team
together - yeah he put that championship
team together now he blew it up but it
just shows you and I hope the younger
generation understands this because I
tried to use some of that material while
we played you know especially on Scotty
like you know suddenly at free-throw
lines now I can't believe they're trying
to get rid of you dude are you kidding
you know I would use a little bit during
the game but it goes to show you how
strong
MJ mentally was I mean you want five
championships and you've got all this on
your shoulders this dude was so mentally
strong and focused you couldn't crack
him
you just couldn't crack him but like you
got you're very competitive obviously
and so is he and you knew that there was
going to be a moment where this was come
this would come to a head yes and I
think a part of it maybe he was trying
to tell it look it didn't matter I just
knew I knew that we were going to be on
the collision course I just how my
nature is and it's hard for me to hold
my tongue and I think being baptized
during the summers at Durham I UCLA days
by magic and and Michael Cooper and
Byron Scott telling me never to back
down always take two steps forward and
being a young kid and very
impressionable
you know never helped anyone up you
never you know you never bowed out you
never never do that I don't care who the
man is in front of you and I just could
never hold my tongue and being in our
arena and having our friends cheer for
him it burned me it did I don't know it
just I was there was a rage inside of me
and it made me want to be better
that's what MJ did he made other people
want to it just made me want to be
better because you wanted to be on his
same footing which was never going to
happen for a player like me but in my
head I thought though I just I and I
tell people that I was in Atlanta at a
Hawks game and it felt like 80% of the
Omni was there rooting for the Bulls
they were just like I don't know if
we'll ever have a team where it feels
like everybody was fascinated by them
love them couldn't wait for them to get
to town even if it meant beating your
team what was it about the Bulls that we
saw that we'll probably never see again
and if you look at that the episode when
they're in France
I think the late Commissioner kind of
echoed that right that's why I think it
was going to be so hard to ever beat
them because they were going to get
every benefit of the doubt calls because
they were the team you are going to have
to truly beat the Bulls it wasn't going
to be happen chance it wasn't going to
be them you had to beat MJ and Scottie
and Dennis and I think the commissioners
words echoed that because they were the
team they were our cash cow and when
they came in to Old Market Square Arena
and again we're only three two and a
half three hours drive apart so close
proximity between Indiana Indianapolis
and and obviously playing in Chicago so
a lot of their fans could drive up to
games buy our tickets are good seats and
cheer for them so not until we started
to get good while he was playing
baseball and in 93 94 and on once we
started to get a great home base because
we started to win and we started to see
success and our fans started to rally
and get behind that so then once we
played them during the playoffs it was
more 80 percent fans for us and 20
percent fans as opposed to it being as
you mentioned you know 6040 them 70/30
them so we by the time we started
winning our fan base had changed because
we wanted to beat MJ we wanted to be
that team talking to Reggie Miller the
hall-of-famer
Turner Sports NBA analyst and one of the
great shooters in the history of the
game speaking of which would you have
rather have had Pippen on you or Jordan
on you out of both I would much rather
have MJ on me because MJ
no offense he'd like to take great
defender don't get me wrong
unbelievable probably the one of the
best on balls defenders ever but but but
I stayed in motion there was so I'd
never stopped moving and I knew that he
wanted to exert a lot of energy
offensive end it was my job to take a
little bit of steam out those legs so I
knew that he would always take corners
by not walking and trailing me he would
always try to go over the screens when
I'm over playing the passing lanes he
was playing the passing lanes all the
time because he didn't want to exert
that energy of staying with me and being
in a marathon all game so I could get
clean looks Scotty was much taller
longer and stick to the principles
though he didn't guard me a lot because
back then you guarded your man you had
to guard MJ MJ had to guard you there
wasn't a lot of switching and all that
though you could ask my good friend Marv
Jackson how it feels to have Scottie
Pippen on oh because during that seven
game series he'll put Scottie on Michael
and that change our body put on mark and
that changed the complexity of that
series because it took you know 12 to 14
seconds just to get the ball in court
and we were we couldn't get into our
office quickly so that would be a better
question for Mark Jackson and it would
be for me when you first heard that
Michael was going to leave and go play
baseball what was your reaction I was
shocked obviously it opened up not only
my career and the Pacers because we took
off but you know people question does
Houston get those two rings if MJ
doesn't you know go back 205 right do
you think I will say this
Alijah one was a handful huh you know I
don't know
he'll never know that I'm going to give
them respect they won back-to-back
championships and let's leave it at that
I also was thinking about this with the
draft and you know you drafted four
positions back then you a portly needed
a big man though then went
you know the chemos to the Rockettes and
then Mike goes to the Bulls they don't
take Mike because they have Clyde
Drexler
but in today's NBA you'd go hey that's
where that's where available yes and he
may have gone one he may have gone if
you're drafting today though it had been
hard to pass up at the time Hakeem
Olajuwon now Hakeem Olajuwon because to
me he's one of the top seven or eight
players ever Hakeem so but at the time
Sam Bowie was the correct call out of
Kentucky
a big man could stretch the floor could
shoot could rebound no one saw the
injuries that he went through and ended
up having a solid career not great but
obviously he he didn't live up to the
name in Portland but I believe he played
pretty well when he was in New Jersey
when he got traded there and had a
serviceable career but didn't have the
Jordan like career but nobody knew that
Mike was gonna be Mike Meany at the
jumper win a national title but you know
in fairness to some of these other GM's
Rod Thorn of the Bulls he didn't know
that Mike was gonna be Mike if you
redrafted then Mike's gonna go number
one obviously but you know at the time
the Keene was Hakeem was a better
college player Patrick Ewing was a
better college player you had guys who
were better than Michael in my opinion
we just didn't know that Mike was going
to explode and be something that we
hadn't seen before
when did you forget the like your first
in person because here you are already
in the league and you know so the first
time around you're hearing a Jordan man
he's a bad dude man you're like okay
right
well I got it early even before he got
well may have been his rookie year there
was at the time there was an exhibition
between UCLA and North Carolina the
alums as well as the current players and
we played this game in Pauley Pavilion
not somewhere so someone
has footage of this and this was the
actual first time that I got a chance to
go against him and I believe I was still
a senior at UCLA and it might have been
his first a second year in the league
and I remember Kenny Smith being there
and a lot of the Carolina great versus
the CLA greats old and new and having a
chance to you know lock horns with him
and I remember coach hazard was coaching
our team and he just kept putting me on
him go out of glad I would go at him and
I was like but you knew you knew and
it's funny cuz you and I we know MJ
intimately and it's funny looking at
some of those old clips right when he
was drafted in hearing him because he
didn't know he was like I hope to come
in and you know changed the complexity
of the bull like how he talks now and
how he talked in because no as you
mentioned no one knew no one knew and he
didn't know but he quickly turned
everything and the fortunes of our
franchise very quickly when Jordan comes
back from baseball his first game was at
Indy against you guys right you guys won
okay you guys won that game yes we did
and I was so amped because first of all
that's balling because usually most guys
they're gonna wait to play a home game
and be and their normal surrounding
those dudes wants to do it on the road
right and do it against us and we were
you know since he had left us in New
York we were the team's I'm like okay
it's about let's do this he's back you
know so we were excited we were up for
it what would you say if you if you sat
down with him like let's say we went to
dinner and then you see MJ
I might punch him I don't know I don't
know again are you being serious are you
that would be be you would have
different emotions there was a lot of
stuff being thrown back and forth I
respect the heck out of that dude the
greatest I mean he's the greatest but
but what's the whole thing you said that
you you can't let go can you tell me it
just hurts because when you feel I just
felt we should have ended them in 97
that season the one that you know they
had the crew I I felt we were the better
team and it just pains me and hurts it
hurts me so that's so much bitter or
animosity towards him but he didn't say
things to you kidding um look I don't
kiss and tell
okay I've never been that type of player
I'm not going to kiss and tell
okay you know there's a lot of things
said on the on the hard floor and I've
said a lot of things at times maybe I
you know regret but mean-spirited stuff
but means spirit but I don't care you're
not gonna hurt my feelings I'm trying to
hurt your feelings so you're not gonna
hurt my feelings but did you get
personal yes did he get personal yes how
personal and there's nothing wrong with
that but remember I've kind of known MJ
even back to the Sherrill days because
they were both Naismith award winners
and they went to the bank together and I
was there so I didn't know him but you
know he was there with my sister so I
kind of knew and it's funny because
people you know he comes out and says
you know I'm scared people are going to
think I'm a you know they're gonna get a
bad image of me after they see you know
all right dude
I know you are and you know what the
timing of this reg I keep thinking you
know this was LeBrons year you can win a
title with the Lakers you know third
different franchise and then all of a
sudden here's the reminder
LeBron it doesn't matter what you do
this is going to reinforce it even more
where we're gonna go how was this ever a
debate he's probably helping people are
gonna react after this documentary and
everyone is locked at home I mean this
dropped at the look we got or in the
middle of a pandemic people are locked
in their homes nothing but their remotes
in TV and they are publicizing the heck
out of this you were 100% correct this
is a reminder to the younger generation
Oh y'all must have forgot are you going
to watch next Sunday am i coming on
Monday
hell yeah go ahead I like I like the
cliffhanger that they left us with with
the whole sky
first of all Scotty I hope you're that
upset with your agent and I get it that
you took the money and you know Admiral
taking care of the family because that
comes first taking care of family
responsibilities but here's hey Scotty
if the owner tells you it's a bad deal
and I wouldn't take it safe to say don't
take the deal don't come crying back to
me a few years later wanting more money
well gee it was a bad deal you got a
problem with Scotty - or just Michael no
I love Scotty my in Rodman you okay with
Rodman absolutely love I love I do yeah
we could punch him but you could punch
him you wouldn't punch who no I would
not punch because Scotty and I are the
same draft and we were on the 96 Olympic
team nothing but love for Scotty I have
nothing but love for MJ it's just two
guards shooting guards were locked up
we're holding
hitting we're punching and we were just
talking to one another now this is what
made you who you are that you didn't
heat deep down and I don't know what he
says in the documentary but if you
didn't if you didn't walk towards him
then I don't think I think he would
disrespect you I think the fact that you
did it I think he's still probably gonna
disrespect I don't know what he said
about me I don't know how they framed it
but he doesn't like people no nor do I
care what they what he said about me if
it's good or bad
what about Isaiah man he's still that
that'll never go his feelings for lack
thereof of Isaiah that's real and vice
versa I'm guessing that's real that's
real I was knee-deep in that man need it
now buddy buddy come on man be on my
Instagram FaceTime jack come on dude
let's hang up you think I'm trying to
get in jail on an Instagram live come on
man talk to you soon on this show man I
miss you man we'll talk soon Thank You
reg you got that's Reggie Aloysius
Miller junior that there